1982 les chercheurs avaient trouvé une
solution pour soulager les patients
atteints de maladies lourdes le cannabis
thérapeutique on se servirait de dérives
et modifié à partir des principes actifs
du cannabis pour empêcher les
vomissements induits par la
chimiothérapie que l'on donne aux
cancéreux ce traitement sont très
difficiles à supporter c'est une parole
rare dans le milieu médical français
surtout à cette période pour que le
cannabis thérapeutique soit à nouveau
abordée il faut attendre 1996 année où
la californie a décidé de le légaliser
à san francisco de nombreux malades du
sida y avaient recours de manière
illicite
quand j'utilise la marijuana ça m'aide
ça soulage la douleur ça m'évite de
prendre deux comprimés comme de la
mangue frimousses des dérivés de
morphine et en plus ça stimule mon
appétit en france le cannabis est classé
comme drogue depuis 1970 au même titre
que la cocaïne ou l'héroïne hors de
question de suivre l'initiative
californienne malgré les demandes
répétées de patients chiche souffre
qu'on m'ait jamais ricains donc dans
l'or dans la même situation je devrais
pouvoir mais des fichiers des mêmes
possibilités dans les années 2000 alors
que le débat s'ouvre tout se divisent
les malades la communauté scientifique
et la classe politique depuis des années
il ya une confusion des genres entre le
traitement de la douleur avec des
médicaments du stupéfiant et
l'utilisation de molécules stupéfiante
dans le cadre de la toxicomanie
certains fument malgré tout dans
l'illégalité
un cadre médical et légal pour
l'utilisation du cannabis thérapeutique
non pas à fumer mais dans des
médicaments des politiques de gauche
comme de droite ils n'y sont pas opposés
comme le député ump richard dell'agnola
en 2003
s'il est avéré que le cannabis peut dans
certaines maladies lourdes graves
pathologies améliorer le les traitements
et peut-être soulager la douleur
pourquoi pas
dix ans plus tard en juin 2013 un décret
a ouvert la voie à la mise sur le marché
de médicaments à base de cannabis
nouvelle étape en juin 2019
c'est le début d'une phase de deux ans
d'expérimentation le temps d'évaluer les
modes d'administration de la molécule
ainsi que la possibilité d'une filière
de production de cannabis made in france
[Musique]